Um,
you know,
you hear very frequently people say
things like everyone's creative.
It's like that's wrong,
okay,
it's wrong.
It's just as wrong as saying that
everyone's extroverted,
first of all,
you have to be pretty damn smart to be
creative because otherwise you're just
going to get to where other people have
already got and that's not creative by
definition.
So,
so being fast and being out there at the
front of things really makes a
difference.
And then you also have to have these
divergent thinking capabilities and
that's part of your traits.
Structure and creative people are really
different than non creative people,
you know,
partly because for example,
they're highly motivated to do creative
things and to experience novelty and to
end to end,
to chase down aesthetic experiences into
a 10 movies and to read fiction and to
go to museums and to enjoy poetry and,
and,
and to enjoy music that's not
conventional music for example.
These aren't trivial differences.
And so and so it's a real,
it's a real misstatement to make the
proposition that everyone's creative.
It's just simply not the case.
It's a matter of wishful thinking.
It's like saying that everyone's
intelligent,
it's like,
well,
if everyone's intelligent than then the
term loses all of its meaning because
any term that you can apply to every
member of a category,
it has absolutely no meaning.
Now that doesn't end.
You know?
The other thing you want to be thinking
about here is that don't be thinking
that creativity is such a good thing.
It's a high risk,
high return strategy,
so if you're creative,
you just try this.
There's creative people in this room,
man,
you guys are gonna.
Have a hell of a time monetizing your
creativity.
It's virtually impossible.
It's really,
really difficult because first of all,
let's say you make an original product,
you think the world will beat a pathway
to your door.
If you build a better mouse trap.
It's like that's complete rubbish.
It isn't.
It isn't true in the least.
If you make a good creative product,
you've probably solved about five
percent of your problem because then you
have marketing which is insanely
difficult and then you have sales and
then you have customer support and then
you have to build an organization and
you have to.
If it's really novel,
you have to tell people what the hell
the thing is,
you know,
we built this future authoring program,
right,
and it's available for people online,
so how do you market that?
No one knows what that is and that's a
real problem.
If you read a book while then you have
the problem that another million people
have also written a book,
but if you produce something that's
completely new and doesn't have a
category,
people can't search for it online,
how are they going to find it so you you
just have and then you have pricing
problems and it's really unbelievably
difficult to produce something creative
and then monetize it and even worse,
if you're the creative person,
let's say you have a spectacular
invention,
you've got no money,
right?
You've got no customers,
no,
those are big problems and so maybe you
go and you find a venture capitalist.
We start with family and friends because
that's how it works.
He raised money for your product.
You raise money from your family and
friends.
That's assuming you have family and
friends that have some money and that
they're going to give it to you and most
people aren't in that situation,
so it's a terrible barrier right off the
bat and then of course you're putting
your family and friends at substantial
financial risk because the probability
that you're stupid idea is going to make
money is virtually zero even if it's a
really brilliant idea and so then let's
say,
well you get past family and friends and
you get venture capitalists,
capitalists involved because that's
often the next step or an angel investor
that's there's steps in building a
business,
family and friends,
Angel investor that some rich guy that
you happened to meet some manner in some
way.
Who's who's into this sort of thing is
is willing to provide you with some
money to get your product off the
ground?
Well,
how much of your product is that person
going to take?
Well,
most of it,
and then if you get a venture and no
wonder because you know you don't have
any money,
how are you going to bargain for control
over your product?
He'll just say,
well,
do you want the money or not,
and if your answer is no,
then he'll go and do something else with
his money.
It's not like there's no shortage of
things that you can do with your money.
There's a million things you can do with
it so you're not in a great bargaining
position and then if you get venture
capitalists involved,
they'll take another big chunk and maybe
if they're not very straight with you,
they'll just throw you out because maybe
by that point in the company's
development,
you're nothing but a pain in the neck
because what do you know about marketing
and sales and customer service and
building an organization and running a
business like you don't have a clue,
so why do they need you?
So even if you're a successful at
generating a new idea and you put it
into a business,
the probability that you as the
originator of the idea are going to make
some money from it is very,
very low.
So don't be thinking that creativity is
such a.
is such a something you would want to
curse yourself with.
Now,
you know,
it's not all bad because it opens up
avenues of experience for creative
people that aren't available to people
who aren't creative,
but it definitely is a high risk,
high return strategy,
you know,
so the overwhelming probability is that
you will fail,
but a small proportion of creative
people succeed spectacularly.
And so it's like a lottery in some
sense.
You're probably gonna lose,
but if you don't lose,
you could win big and that keeps a lot
of creative people going.
But also they don't really have much
choice in it because if you're a
creative person,
you're like to have a fruit tree that's,
that's bearing fruit so you don't really
have,
you can suppress it,
but it's very bad for,
you know,
the creative people I've worked with as
if they're not creative,
they're miserable so they have to do it.
But,
and,
and you know,
there's real joy and pleasure in it and,
and,
and psychological utility.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's an intelligent,
it's certainly not a conservative
strategy for moving forward through
life.
So,
and you know,
whenever I talk to people who are
creative and you guys should listen to
this because I know what I'm talking
about,
if you happen to be creative,
if you're a songwriter or another kind
of musician or an artist or or or any of
the other number of things that you
might be,
find a way to make money and then
practice your craft on the side because
you will starve to death otherwise.
Now some for some of you that will be
true,
but it's a tiny minority.
You're best bet is to find a job that
will keep body and soul together and
parse off some time that you can pursue
your creative thing because then,
well as a longterm strategy,
medium to longterm strategy,
it's a better one.
But it's got incredibly difficult for
people.
Musicians,
for example.
It's incredibly difficult for new
musicians to monetize their craft even
if they're really,
really good at it.
So it's,
it's,
well,
so anyway,
so don't be.
So I say,
well,
everyone's not.
Everyone's not creative.
And everybody goes,
oh,
that's terrible.
It's like,
it's not so terrible.
It's not something.
It's not self evident that you would
curse someone with high levels of
creativity.